نحن نسمع عن هذه الخسائر الفادحة
للجيش الروسي،
أنت تعرف بوتين جيدًا، لقد كنت
تراقبه عن كثب، ماذا ترى
الآن
جيدًا، أرى أنه
في نوع من الخسارة،
إذا حكمنا من خلال أفعاله، كما تعلمون
جسديًا  يبدو أنه في
حالة جيدة أفضل بكثير مما كان عليه في
الربيع في أبريل ومايو على سبيل المثال، ولكن إذا حكمنا من خلال
تصرفاته، فهو
يرتكب أخطاء، فهو يتصرف بطريقة
غير منتظمة، كما تعلمون
الكثير من الأشياء التي تبدو
منطقية مثل أنه يعين شخصًا  شخص يقوم
بترقية شخص واحد، ثم في غضون
شهرين يقوم بتخفيض رتبته، فهو يمنح
الكثير من القوة للاحتياطات ويأخذ
السلطة من الاحتياط مرة أخرى، الأمر نفسه ينطبق على
الوساطة مع رئيس
الوزراء، لذلك يبدو الأمر كما لو
كنت تعرف  كما لو كان في
حيرة، فهو يفهم أن عليه أن
يتصرف لكنه لا يعرف ماذا يفعل، لذلك
تتحرك يداه من تلقاء نفسها
وهو فقط يغير الموازين
والموازنات ويخلق
توازنات جديدة ونمطًا جديدًا يوازن
الأشياء التي يريدها.  كان يفعل ذلك
لسنوات عديدة اعتاد على
القيام به ولكن الآن هذا
وضع مختلف فهو يحتاج إلى نوع مختلف من
الإجراءات وهو غير قادر على تقديم ذلك
الآن في هذا السياق هنا لمشاهدة
بوتين، أعلم أنك تركز على
الانتخابات الرئاسية الروسية المقبلة
وتعتقد أن بوتين بحاجة إلى الإعلان عن
ترشحه في الأشهر المقبلة لذلك إذا
كان سيترشح عليه أن يعلن
ذلك أه في الأشهر المقبلة لكن
تعتقد أنه قد يلغي الانتخابات ماذا
يعني ذلك إذا
حكمنا من خلال تصرفاته الأخيرة عندما
يتصاعد أه باستمرار دون
ضرورة قد يلغي الانتخابات فعلا أه أه
فهم أنه
بدون الانتصار على أوكرانيا
سيواجه صعوبات حقيقية صعبة في
الحصول على أغلبية أصوات
الروس الذين تعرفهم دون إثبات
أنه قوي الروس تعرفون الروس
لا  لن أحتاج إليه إذا لم يكن قوياً
حتى
يتمكن من إعلان الأحكام العرفية
وإلغاء الانتخابات